we grew a three million person audience
in 18 months and what we didn't do was
say hey like And subscribe and follow
after every single one of our videos
people don't respond to more than one
call to action if you want someone to do
something only tell them one thing to do
at a time and if you want to tell them
multiple things to do tell them one
thing to do at different times within
the content you can have someone go to
your podcast you can have someone like
you can have someone subscribe but not
at the same time tell them the first
thing you want them to do and if you
have a multitude step process then tell
them the second thing to do after
they've done the first thing and if you
want bonus points to get a higher
percentage people even to do that frame
the second thing as a continuation of
the first because what happens is
psychologically this becomes commitment
and consistency so people like to see
themselves as not wasting their time and
being consistent with what they just did
if you show them that they incur a cost
by taking the first step they'll be more
likely to take the second